or Fallout to the stunning and truly
unprecedented FBI raid that we saw in
the early morning hours yesterday at
Donald Trump's Mar-A-Lago home Democrats
and the media appearing to relish the
possible legal trouble that the
president could face washes tomorrow is
the day when you're going to want to buy
the physical copy of the newspaper
because this is a night where you are
going to remember where you were
obviously as big as big as Stakes as you
can have perhaps the orange jumpsuit is
for is forthcoming Vladimir Putin he he
doesn't believe in the rule of law uh
she doesn't they all systematically work
to break down the rule of law just like
Donald Trump if I were like Donald
Trump's lawyer right now and thank God
I'm not
um I would be advising my client to be
telling my family I am looking at jail
time and we should you know make plans
accordingly
so you've seen those faces uh nodding
knowingly before many many times right
and speaker Nancy Pelosi dismissed
concerns that the raid will shake the
country's confidence in our rule of law
and in the FBI
no one is above the law not even a
president or former president of the
United States but that all of this will
shall be made known to us over time but
I have no knowledge of it I do know that
there has been chatter or what more than
chatter about the presidential
president's documents and how they must
be preserved for history
so Greg when I watch those reactions I
watch Rachel Maddow I watch Neil cattell
saying that it's time for the former
president to tell his family that he's
going to jail my mind goes back to the
CIA director Brennan right there will be
indictments there will be plenty of them
right how many times have we been down
this road when are these folks going to
learn that you that you don't know yet
what's going on you don't know what's in
this warrant you don't know what they
have and it's wiser to keep your mouth
shut and say you know what until I
actually see the affidavit and I see the
case they've got we'll see what happens
well I get it I mean ratings I mean they
if you just if we went on the five and
said we don't know the show would be
dead so on we're in the world of
speculation so are they however their
speculation always wrong walls are
closing in boom this is it it's worse
than Watergate and then it goes away but
um they're reelecting him by the way but
just by the way they're talking but the
one thing some advice to the people at
home is you could be really pissed off
at this but you have to have fun with it
too because the Press wants you to react
angrily because that's the second bite
to this apple they're already doing
pieces about
um pro-trump message boards you know
enraged surely there's going to be
another January 6th there's going to be
you know uh you know gangs of of people
in Red Hats causing problems so you want
to take that away from them you want to
look at this you know soberly and have
fun with it uh they want an excuse to
track down more Republicans and people
in Red Hats and you don't want to give
it to them so I think that's a setup I
also find it interesting and sad that
when something big happens to somebody
that they don't like the media doesn't
care we aren't like that and I'm going
to use Alec Baldwin as an example when
that when that tragedy occurred we're
extremely sympathetic even though we
knew that if the shoe was on the other
foot I Alec Baldwin would have been on
Twitter laughing at Jesse waters for
shooting me you know it would have been
he thought it would be the funniest
thing ever so we are actually they
should actually try to table I probably
would have missed yeah you would have
they shouldn't need to table their
emotional ideology but they won't
Jesse they get a sick sexual thrill from
trying to block up Republicans it's a
perversion you know they like to see
them dragged out in their underwear at
dawn while CNN cameras are staked out
there you've seen it all before I mean
they've wanted to block Trump up from
the very moment he was inaugurated
they've tried I think rated both of his
lawyers homes they've rated his
Associates homes they'll pull anybody
out in their pajamas to humiliate them
because they're just bloodthirsty
radical Communists it's a lot easier to
throw your political enemies in jail
than actually go out there debate
persuade and beat them they've merged
with the National Security State and
there's a group and you're either in the
group or you're out of the group if
you're in the group you'll never get in
trouble and this Security State will
look out for your financial interest for
the interests of your family but if
you're not in this group
they're going to strip search you do a
whole full body cavity search of you and
humiliate you and your family for the
rest of your life that's why when the
Republicans take power back they can't
just like hold hearings they have to go
in clean house disbar people you know
pull this corrupt thing up from the root
because it's disgusting and sick Nancy's
up there saying no one's Above the Law
what about Nancy I mean she's fresh off
the heels of insider trading allegations
or her husband's been crooked for the
last three decades and she does this she
flies her other crooked son over on a
government jet to Asia and he's trying
to cook up lithium deals and electric
car battery deals and all the places she
happens to be going to and then she
scrubs the internet and the transcripts
of all indications that she brought her
crooked son over there I mean he's like
Hunter Biden without the crack pipe you
look at Hunter Biden talk about Above
the Law I mean they have emails texts
National Security flag from the treasury
Department voicemails from the big guy
saying they're getting Kickbacks on tape
witness testimony that this guy was
involved in an international pay for
play scheme with some of our greatest
enemies the Chinese and the Russians but
they have the FBI covering that up
before an election you know who's Above
the Law it's the Democratic party Harold
how do you feel about that because
that's something that I hear from a lot
of people they feel like there's been a
destruction of the rule of law they look
at this laptop and the evidence has been
out there for everyone to see there's
drug use there's you know flailing
weapons around there's
um you know likely prostitution on these
two and then it doesn't matter if he's
just a screwed up you know son of a
president the problem is that he's in
deals with the Chinese and the Russians
as Jesse just said and they go well
what's happening with that how does that
get buried at the FBI Chuck Grassley
Senator Grassley is like you know very
upstanding Senator
um he he wants to know what the heck is
going on I I have no clue uh what I do
know is that I think this investigation
that's a couple questions I think the
investigation with Hunter Biden started
when President Trump was in office U.S
attorney did he appointed and I think
the investigation from what I understand
continues and I hope wherever the facts
lead them that the law follows very
closely I don't believe anyone is above
the law I think any any person every
person is presumed innocent until proven
otherwise in our country be it Hunter
Biden Hillary Clinton or Donald Trump
this conversation uh you know I'm always
when when someone else when someone is
accused of something and people start
talking about other people that's fine
but if we don't talk about this this
particular issue here all I would ask
Democrats on TV to do is everybody take
a breath Everybody Take Take It calm
down a bit as Greg said from the outset
and let's set the facts drive this this
was an unprecedented evening last night
no former president has had his home uh
had a search warrant served in his home
like this and rate it and I'd start and
where I started last last segment
release the warrant let us have an
understanding of why they did this
because it may actually get us closer to
the ending that some of some at the
table a project may actually happen he
did it again
just an American right here release the
warrant yeah that's what I would do
accuse me of this
really
let me tell you something they can put
anything they want in the warrant you
just said the facts should drive this
let me tell you what the facts are
that's what that's the term you use the
fact you're driving I know you do I
think it's a good thing let me tell you
what the facts are the facts are that
Hillary Clinton deleted 33 000 emails
most of them classified after they were
subpoenaed that's called the destruction
of evidence the fact is she was not
prosecuted because James Comey who cut
her loose when he was ahead of the
southern district in New York on the
Clinton Foundation decided he was going
to cut her loose instead of the Attorney
General the facts are that there was
perjured testimony but for a fisa judge
the facts are they continued to lie to
that bison judge to re-up the warrant so
let's talk about the facts the facts are
that the Democrats will say or do
anything to destroy Donald Trump because
he's not part of that Network he is the
only person who's been fighting for the
American people and let me tell you
something if the president if the
Republicans get back on office I don't
want them to have hearings I don't want
them to clean house I want them to start
Prosecuting I want them to start to make
sure that people respond to Law and
Order that they listen to what the rules
are and that they follow them because
until the Democrats are taught to do
that they will abuse the law and we will
be the victims of their government uh
oversight overrule
okay I'd release the search more
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else